it's a devastating time and it's hard to
do anything but be heartbroken over what
happened to George Floyd and his family
and you know that one of my hopes that
rise out of those protests is that
there's like a set of changes that
people demand because the danger is that
all of this energy and heart and spirit
and passion ends up getting channeled
but like no one knows what to do so we
need to fight for something real and
concrete
[Music]
it's been a devastating and
heartbreaking time in our country every
night we're either transfixed by what's
happening on streets around the country
or in some cases we're on the streets
ourselves I mean there there are curfews
that have been implemented in dozens of
cities but I saw a report this morning
saying that 10,000 people have been
arrested in relation to the protests and
you know that's a very very small
fraction of the folks who've been
marching so you're looking at hundreds
of thousands of people who've been
gathering and protesting around the
country I went to a vigil here in
upstate New York and hundreds of people
came out and we all saw what happened to
George Floyd having his life
extinguished before our eyes it's like
how many people are killed by police
every year and the sick part is you
don't know that it's unclear how many
people died in encounters with police or
in police custody every year because the
data is not reported despite the fact
that a law was passed that asked the
Department of Justice to compile this
report but they just never have gotten
the data because it's dependent upon
police departments submitting and so you
have 18,000 police departments around
the country and the best estimates are
that 2,000 or more Americans die in
contact with police annually cities
spend hundreds of millions of dollars a
year on settlements for police brutality
cases New York City alone spends 300
million a year on direct payments
liability Chicago 47 million nationwide
you're looking at about a billion
dollars or more annually and if you
think about what that means you know
that only a small fraction of the people
that actually would have a legitimate
case can successfully sue the city and
get a settlement so you're looking at
billions of
dollars easily in liability and the
billion dollars I'm talking about is
just direct payouts it doesn't include
lawyers fees which we know can be
massive or insurance which we know can
be massive
that's just payouts to people that's
just payouts directly to families so
looking at it objectively you'd have to
say okay this is a very significant
problem and you know it's a significant
problem in part because the district
attorney is bringing suits against
police officers who are accused of
misconduct but if you look at the
incentives of the DA the DA works with
police officers hand-in-hand every
single day to make cases the last thing
they want to do is go to war over some
police misconduct and it's similar for
the local mayor like the mayor's best
friend is likely the police chief and
mayor does not want to go to war with
law enforcement in their community
because there's some of the most
powerful constituents in the community
so you're looking at a massive problem
the scope of which you don't really even
know because we don't have the data and
we all know if there had not been a
video of George Floyd being killed it
just would have been another unnoticed
death so there's frustration there's
anger there's fear and anxiety but to me
in the conversations I've been having
there's a sense of helplessness as you
watch this unfold you know you wake up
every morning and you see another
horrific instance and you're like what
what can I actually do where's the first
place we can start as a society to start
fixing this well there are studies that
have been done as to what we can do to
improve police violence and the work
that campaign zero has done I find
really compelling because it's very
data-driven one of the leaders there is
a data scientist and so they have six
recommendations that have been proven to
work and they're not easy because again
you're talking about 18,000 police
departments but one thing that was on
the list was federal over
when the Department of Justice has
investigated Police Department's
incidents of police brutality have
dropped significantly and so one thing
I've championed is that we should have a
new George Floyd police misconduct
Division of the Department of Justice
that is dedicated to police misconduct
issues around the country because if you
look at it objectively the local law
enforcement officials are gonna have a
very hard time bringing suits against
other law enforcement officials in their
vicinity if you're a good cop or DA or
the mayor you are thrilled that there's
someone who can come in and administer
and prosecute these matters that's not
you because in your case like you're
picking a fight with someone who's in
your backyard but if you have the feds
come in then they can be objective and
hold people accountable you've thought
about this task force a lot so actually
be interesting to see how this would
work so theoretically you're the DA in
Minneapolis would you be the one calling
this task force to come in or the this
task force see it objectively and it's
like it's out of your hands we make the
decision like how does it mechanically
how does this work or how would you want
it to work Oh in this case the because
of we can all see an enormous public
pressure like the district attorney has
brought charges against four officers
involved right but in the absence of
this kind of situation where it's
legally in the national spotlight you'd
have the independent investigators who
who act like the FBI where they can be
called in by local law enforcement but
they could be called in by local members
of the community too so why don't you
talked about data one of the things
we've struggled with is there's not a
lot of it the data is rough which is a
major problem and that leads us to
number two you need to track complaints
and you need to keep a database of
officers who are fired or disciplined
because right now what happens is you
can fire a bad cop and then they'll
leave that town or state and then go
someplace else and then get rehired the
other piece of this are how to
deescalate a situation in most these
situations are not inherently violent
right
so that there are a range of situations
where you call someone and you'd prefer
that they show up and resolve the
situation in a non-violent way and so
there there are two elements to this one
is trying to train police officers to
have a continuum of use of force where
deadly force is the absolute absolute
last resort but the other thing which is
what I was suggesting is that you could
have non police organizations that are
able to respond to emergency calls in
Oregon they have this crisis assistance
helping out on the street organization
where you have crisis workers and mental
health providers who can respond to
incidents involving homelessness
substance abuse mental health crises and
in these situations you don't need
someone showing up like saying hey I
like Who am I here to pull a gun on like
a quarter of police shooting victims are
mentally ill majority of mentally ill
people are not violent are not
threatening but if you're a police
officer and you're in the situation
you're like well snapped like that you
know this person is not listening
anything I'm saying you know halt or
I'll shoot and then the person doesn't
halt there are a lot of situations where
you need help but you don't necessarily
need police help like you don't think
it's like a life-or-death situation
that's going to involve a firearm is
that related to demilitarizing the
police I know you've had some comments
on that too and we were talking about
one of our colleagues went to protest
and said it was extremely peaceful and
the cops showed up who were also
peaceful but they were decked out in
riot gear and everybody got on edge and
then it got wild Oh riot gear is not the
half of it
Zak I mean there's a pentagon program
that actually allows the military to
send
surplus military equipment to police and
sheriff's departments so you have some
of these 18,000 police departments
around the country that have tanks and
armored vehicles and grenade launchers
and military-style hardware and studies
have shown that when you have this
military equipment in place you use it
and then if you use it you're more
likely to wind up with deaths resulting
from police action so this Pentagon
program was discontinued
Barack Obama's administration and then
was reversed by the Trump administration
which is not surprising and so we need
to rein this in and that makes sense
from a human perspective as well like
just putting more people on edge so when
I went to a vigil police officers were
there but it was a hundred percent
peaceful would it have been different if
those police officers had those face
masks on a riot gear and like best and
night sticks it would have given a very
different energy and in many cases if
you're a protester showing up like
you're agitated obviously and so if
there's a police officer there who let's
say is just wearing normal outfit you
can see their face and interact with you
like a human then you're more likely to
have like a less negative or violent
interaction with them than if they're
like a faceless military-style looking
figure and I think it's true on both
sides like I genuinely think if you
cover my face with a mask and give me a
baton like I'm more likely to be an
[ __ ] then if you can see my face and
I'm looking at you I die right I'm
really interested and I'm interested in
your thoughts on this on the the
community aspect of this like what have
you seen there is a good solution that
could work there have been positive
examples of community based policing
where police officers regularly
volunteer and spend time in like rec
centers and plainclothes where it's not
always just rolling up in the cruiser
like in full uniform and then you you
wind up with more trust being developed
in both directions
[Music]
this episode of Yang speak is brought to
you by an outer known so I got a couple
things I'm out of known and I'm a way
down where I'm one of them was a pair of
jeans because I'm in Florida and it's
super hot and I put these jeans on and
they're fantastic so checking all the
boxes that I've got shirts I got button
downs I got sweaters and I now have
jeans Kelly Slater former pro surfer
world champion you've done it but this
company is awesome you know the great
thing is that you know that these
clothes were produced with fair living
wages factory safe working conditions
you can actually wear them with a clear
conscience we're in a culture now where
you've like these disposable clothing I
cannot believe how cheap a lot of
clothes are when you get out there these
clothes feel different they feel better
and you feel better so go to a door
known calm today and enter my code yang
at checkout and you'll get 25% off your
full price order that's adorned own
dot-com oh you ter KN o WN calm and use
my code yang at checkout for 25% off use
yang little jig it's legit discount so
get 1/4 off this thing do it it's
awesome
[Music]
so one thing that has not worked at
least demonstrably and this is going to
pain a lot of people is like implicit
bias trainings and empathy trainings
it's like that if you go in and you say
you know we're all biased against
certain people like you may've developed
by a C's too and then you try and see
whether that changed behavior right and
they have been able to demonstrate that
it has doesn't mean that it doesn't work
right but they have been able to
demonstrate that it does work and
there's similar data on body cameras
right to know and body cams like I love
body cams because common sense to me
it's like look if I shoot someone in the
dead of night and it's just me in that
person I shot and there's no footage
they'll be like hey like person attacked
me you know and then you don't know at
least the footage is
another data point yeah I agree it's
these things are helpful but not
necessarily affecting the numbers right
like like like I don't have any
illusions that like putting body cams on
on cops like all of a sudden I'm like
you know all the problems go away
yeah but I will say that like you know
there have been times when you can refer
to the footage and you're like okay like
I have a pretty good sense what happened
here and you know you saw the opposite
of it I don't know if you just saw like
a police chief was fired in Kentucky in
Louisville because barbecue restaurant
owner was shot and they didn't have
their body cams on and so I like that
they looked and said like what is going
on right so I think that's like a useful
standard it's like people body cams say
we expect them to be on and then if the
body cam wasn't on then you know you can
start unfortunately like saying like
well I think something happened here
that shouldn't happen particularly if
you know someone has been shot and
killed so so the data is inconclusive on
body cams but I will say like I'm
enthusiastically for body cams right now
just give them especially because like
we hold people in other contexts that
standards we hold bank tellers
yeah bank tellers call center employees
a hotel employees convenience store it's
like you know that that stuff's getting
recorded and police officers it's
literally life or death
so you know if you have the capacity to
record I feel like you definitely should
so the two other things that they've
shown work makes sense number one or
number four depending upon your
accounting is get rid of the language
and police union contracts that limits
officer accountability where if an
officer is called up on some kind of
complaint or discipline these contracts
often protect them in various ways and
if that language gets changed then
complaints go down so that's something
that's difficult because you have union
contracts that are different across the
country but behavior changes have you
changed those union rules then the other
thing you were saying before about
training where if police departments
have restrictions on chokeholds or
certain techniques this brings down
abuse and fatality rates right and so
this suggests that we should be looking
at national standards which would go
into training so you're talking about
some of your oxys and protections within
police union contracts so there's an
officer during the parkland shooting
there one like school cop hid behind his
police car and didn't go inside the
building
and that officer was fired but then I
think it was fifteen months later after
firing him for neglect of duty they were
forced to hire him back with back pay
because firing him was a violation of
his rights based on the union contract
under those pretenses and so what a
prime example of like if they want to
fire somebody they can't yeah I mean if
you have a police officer who's on the
scene and could have prevented massive
loss of life that was that officers job
in moment of truth and if they meant you
know shrank from that then like if
you're a community like do you want that
officer
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is also
brought to you by Kant screwed up Lee
I mean freshly which is basically
idiot-proof cooking and essentially guys
they bring you meals and as someone who
screws a lot of his cooking up I've been
loving this because I tried to make
shrimp scampi the other night with my
family because I'm 32 years old living
at home in quarantine and the shrimp
were disaster so I'm now using freshly
way more often and I look like a good
chef when I do it I feel like a good
chef so I can't screw it up
yes you know if that can't screw it up
it must be a great product
I'm sure fresh Lee's chefs and
nutritionists do all the hard work all
you do is heat for three minutes and
that's dinner and that sounds like
exactly what so join almost one and a
half million satisfied customers skip
the shopping and the prepping and the
cooking fresh Lee is offering our
listeners $40 off their first two orders
at freshly calm slash yang
that's fresh Lee calm slash yang for $40
off of food that's $40 off some food
can't screw it up Lee know it's freshly
and you'll thank us and it's delicious I
[Applause]
think it's clearly freaking wrong that
these cops killed a man while arresting
him when it was completely unnecessary
and it's extremely wrong that our system
hasn't been fixed in decades of knowing
these problems exist and there's there's
things our government needs to do and I
think people can hold them accountable
or try to but if you're an average
citizen right now what what can we do
what would you recommend individual
people do to start writing these wrongs
it's a devastating time and it's hard to
do anything but be heartbroken over what
happened to George Floyd and his family
but also what's happening around the
country we all have to do everything we
can to help so if you want to help first
just trying to help people in your own
in your own situation be the best person
you can be take care of yourself like
mental health is a crisis on top of a
crisis right now and you know doesn't do
us any good if we're individually not
strong or don't have our head on
straight
in terms of organizations to help there
are a lot of them so I don't want to
just you know say like oh this one or
that one but some of the organizations
that are doing great work in this
direction Color of Change campaign zero
mapping police violence org one of the
organizations I've found working on what
you talked about Andrew where you have
emergency responders that are not
carrying weapons responding to certain
calls that are ideally non-violent
nature it's called white bird clinic org
it's based in Oregon but they have a
program called cahoots which stands for
crisis assistance helping out on the
streets it's mobile Crisis Intervention
24/7 programs like that to me should be
scaled around the country and then the
other thing if you're interested in
policy and getting new ideas out there
Berkeley Chief Justice Earl Warren
Institute of law and Social Policy has
done a lot of work on frankly community
policing and how that works so that's
the earl warren institute of law and
social policy at university of
california berkeley you know that one of
my hopes that rise out of those protests
is that there's like a set of changes
that people demand because the danger is
that all of this energy and heart and
spirit and passion ends up getting
channeled but like no one knows what to
do so we need to fight for something
real and concrete that we can bring to
our communities and George Floyd and his
family and say look George's life and
his death brought about tremendous
change and here are the changes and we
can see them all and that this is a
positive turning point in our nation's
history because of your brother's
sacrifice your you know father sacrifice
like the the obvious one was like well
you need to arrest the officers and now
they've all been arrested but we can
tell that the protest about something
much much bigger
this is the crisis of our time in terms
of racial justice and police brutality
but there are all of these things that
are layered on top of it the fact is
we've set ourselves up by having what
Cornel West called failure upon failure
upon failure for decades where you have
an economy that hasn't created a decent
way of life for millions of people and
then a legal system and a police system
that has not protected people's rights
particularly people of color and you
know one thing I don't mind being is
like the guy who's still talking about
the economy when no one else is because
the economy is still like underpinning
all this stuff like we had another two
million unemployed you know I mean yeah
right now we're adding fuel to the fire
because there's this backdrop of need
and desperation that's rising we're at
depression-era levels of unemployment
yep people are protesting and rioting on
the streets like the minimum you can do
is safeguard people's material
well-being we need to move very fast on
universal basic income because right now
a quarter of the nation's workforce is
out of work
I've seen surveys between 66 and 80% of
Americans agree that we should have cash
relief during this time we're going to
be digging out of this economic
catastrophe for years right and we need
to start right now and and put people in
position where they feel like their
futures are secure right but that said I
think people misunderstand you sometimes
like you are by no means saying that the
money will cure everything it will help
a lot but if you give people money
they're still gonna have massive
injustice in us in the police system
yeah of course I mean the money's not
gonna give George cloyd's family like
they're not it's not return people's
loved ones to them
[Music]
all right this episode of Yanks Peaks is
brought to you by skill share which i
think is essentially the way we're gonna
educate in the future so if you want to
learn aiming from film and video graphic
design or time management or mental
health practices they have online
classes on how to actually tangibly
learn these skills on your own at your
own time and then apply them to your
career your life your family whatever
you think is helpful drawing writing and
journaling classes to help you main
stress during this time interior design
if you're trying to redecorate or
rearrange your your space because you've
been staring at the same place for for
weeks on end a friend of mine actually
founded this company and he's a great
guy and this company is just what the
doctor ordered for many of us explore
your creativity and get two free months
of premium membership at Skillshare comm
slash yang that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free get started and joined today by
heading to Skillshare comm slash yang to
three months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes at skill show comm
slash yang they got a class here on time
management which in productivity which i
think is frankly so needed but this is a
deal guys if you get this stuff for free
for two months
load up on much content as you can so
Skillshare comm slashing
[Music]
so I'm gonna recap to make sure we're
aligned if you're listening this and you
want to help
I think I'm investing just call your
Congressman or congresswoman in your
area or your district call your senator
and here's the things you should ask for
and I Andrew make sure I get these right
one cash relief universal basic income
let's put out the massive unemployment
fire in financial scarcity that's
fueling a lot of desperation in our
communities to is federal oversight at a
federal task force threes better
training for officers which includes
community policing and not using
chokeholds and non violent responses to
emergency calls for is better data and
making sure we track this and we know
exactly what we're measuring and what
we're trying to solve for
and then lastly 5 would be loosening up
these extremely strict bureaucratic
union contracts that are preventing our
institutions from acting those are the
five I have that miss anything or
there's there's the big six
demilitarization have freaking tanks and
grenade launchers out of the hands of
police departments around the country
that should be serving and protecting
and not treating it like a warzone right
so hopefully this is a helpful way to
act for you listening to this
hopefully you feel this this causes that
police or the types of organizations to
start looking for to help we are all
about solutions because to me what we
the worst outcome is that we have these
protests over and over and then nothing
happens that's that's the worst outcome
I believe in already just keep this this
terrible actions these Carroll actions
keep happening yeah so we have to make
real changes in our society and we need
to present a vision for what those
changes must be and then make them real
keep pressure on our leaders until they
become law and people will know that
George's life and his deaths change the
course of history in this country for
the better
[Music]
[Music]